good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Keeton byeongseo from the dragon school
of medical research the australian
national university and i would like to
give another view on an important battle
and I titled the presentation in idiot
can do it how easy knockout animals
could be generating using CRISPR cars
nine genetic technology so before
starting with an important issue which
is applications in gene editing field I
would like to give an overview what my
laboratory is doing we are mainly
microbiology laboratory and were an
interface between microbial genomes in
it in technology genome engineering so
once Co interest is is on exploring by
China and natural genomes and what the
particular interest is is on discovering
new antiviral plasma different system in
bacteria and we are interested in three
main systems or Kyoto models CRISPR cars
systems difference and from there we are
Ness the genetic technology to edit
mouse cells and application such as gene
therapy so for this study today we focus
more on the mouse and the cells so
replication is important so we are
variation crisis in science as you can
see in the screen and a couple of papers
outlining some not a problem in science
which is lack of replication studies the
knock of our ability of the result in
science to appoint us recently a paper
describes this as natural selection of
bad science so the question is what we
can do about it what is
and three factors that are outlined
there the first one is the terms of
underworld studies we are facing the
official very system that the seventh
ages meticulous science and the
structure of the current scholarly
publication and funding model
disadvantaged material segments so the
so let's take an example if you put
myself in proven history you will find
612 eats and to give you an idea one or
two years ago it was only 200 so a lot
of people lot of colleagues are
interested in improving crisper and one
example area was for example a way to
improve genetic technology is to use
what we call inhibitors what these one
who does selects a cr7 is to move also
to improve the generation of point
mutation for in Mouse so how it works we
deliver the cast iron protein or cousin
mRNA with a co 7 reject him through the
mouth I got and what we noticed and you
can see in the columns labeled HDL is
through increased efficiency in in
genetic mutation in Mouse and it's a lot
the problem was and if you look at the
rate we this was only done in and then
flow from wheels not a lot and we were
all twisty on this technique
what we try to do is to advocate
understudy where ours does work a cr7
definitely improving the efficiency the
problem was it is as well a lot of fun
videos therefore we are not able to
widely implemented technique some people
see doing roughly so varied however
there are some drawbacks in using that
so so the read the question is so what
we make up to studies improve the
produce ability in science and
especially in their genetic field and I
give you two examples they are done
asked really illustrates how we can do
as a community to improve the
reliability of the result engineering
field the first one is quite an example
but really tanning is the use of Naga
newts protein called ng echo and the
second one that we have recently
published on the use of a method called
true seekers from the Regal true single
guy dominated sustained from generating
conditional knockout to give another
balloon these different system mechanism
against against Christine and viruses in
bacteria and archaea the wide variety of
difference could be DNA or RNA graded
and you can see in the cartoon it
degrades the pristine original it's a
highly diverse fascinating protein funny
what was the story about it was the use
of DNA guided NGO so national battalion
Grigori
a t-cell mines and what was the claim of
this paper of this paper one firstly the
underdog are capable to edit 37-degree
are generated and to deny the boss
tronic break the song claim was the
editing is almost identical to the Chris
Rock assistant and if you look the
figure at the capital so the a B and C
they will see that it was used to
replace chunk of the genome so we were
very enthusiastic about this paper and
we all tried unfortunately it doesn't
work out that well and I started to
raise some concern about this paper a
month after the publication so two
methods of depreciation so keep in mind
that the deviation was in May 2016 and
early August 2016
I raised some concern about the
technique saying that we have a problem
there it doesn't work as it was
advertised and indeed it was widely
shared and that with 50000 ways in two
days that gives you an idea for this
post to my surprise was in raising
concern about the technique and we keep
rules because it was only two months
after was published and whatever next is
many laboratories trying to advocate
universities and start publish months
after the paper was published so we call
those publication there and we published
indeed
application probably applications to the
year after
so quite a long time and what we found
is in short the Putin is well expressed
in mammalian cells so the Pol Pot a nice
day
not a model doesn't degrade so only it
doesn't lead it
so we try in different systems in
science in mouse and we couldn't find
any editing whereas we could find
editing with crisp assistant so what did
contact with it is of the use of the
envelopes is in fact the NGO enzyme
doesn't edit button Nancy's already so
combination in bacteria how it interacts
with an enzyme with an enzyme that is
important for DNA repair material color
like a so what happened to the paper it
was retracted later and the take-home
message from this is we validate all not
a study by the accumulation of data and
replication studies from the mythical
laboratory it doesn't come for a single
laboratory this is really critical so
the question is okay so we need
replication we need multiple
laboratories but what we can do as a
community and I really would like to
emphasize this example on this technique
and this story can found this neutral in
science that was published and no
subtract 3 or 0 on these positive
statement but and that was that his part
of my title is Anita can't do it and
thus gives you an idea how fast
technology has moved through point now
that we can claim that everyone can do
it and that was the substance of this
crane so what we did we were a little
cheeky is to check the field it is
indeed true so I explained what the
story's about
when we need to generate the conditional
Amin so for example true to knock out a
gene but a specific time and specific
tissue what we do here is CRISPR
technology we excise the exam so you see
as the red red awards and we used to
guys what a train we repair using true
singles credit or you so that it was
inserted into the genome and we have two
rocks PE on the surrounding the example
what happened next
we cross with a clay and it excised
these some basil
so this remember study was published in
2013 in cell and it uses these
techniques to insult a gene called an e
CP 2 as you can see in the cartoon a and
the really rottens fiction would like to
point out is the success rate was good
if you look at the table pissing on the
rest just focus on the railway tambour
and one is pretty clear is the success
rate was around 16 to 15 percent which
was remarkable given that the average
successful 2g9 conditional knockout is
less than 1% with traditional technique
so we were a lot of adjusting and my
laboratory started to replicate these
exact study what I did is to use a
similar mix in writing to the zygote and
look the outcome for editing and so on
and what we did is to find that we could
in certain drugs besides however we
couldn't find the correct insertion and
so there are free take on these is one
of course we might have missed on the
specific experimental condition
certainly we like skis in the laboratory
to successfully insert those laws
besides and fealty it's only on 100 eggs
understand pore sizes were rule so what
we start to discuss within the community
with one of my very good friend come
with common fishermen as a University of
Nebraska we start discussing to discuss
[Music]
what we destroy behaviors through the
laboratory so gurus lab in the misogyny
right Cass bike hike and if you look at
a table we have seen our wizard we
couldn't get correct insertion of the
rocks so again it could be lack of some
pore size under our studies that makes
it difficult winter plant why she
doesn't work so it doesn't tend much so
we what we decided to do is to show the
AG community what we T we ask people
around in the States in Canada in Europe
in UK in Japan Australia so 20
laboratories worldwide what is their
experience with the technology I would
if we are successful not successful and
small and what we ended up with is we
gathered over 5000 site and what we
found is over 80,000 as I got injected
40,000 transferred with close to two
thousand nine cups only 16 because the
consumption focused for those allele and
only 13 genes were successful out of
over 55 which means it requires
something like 1000 eggs
to be injected to see the success which
is considerable and when you take this
into perspective the success rate is
equivalent to the classical targeting
system which is giving an idea that is
not as easy a tizzy it was a good time
so we publish the proteins of our Yahoo
and it was picked up from the news when
we submitted the paper for peer review
free criticism came through and our
faculty season one is the interrogated
lack of skills so for me the world
differences in mouse trends with initial
study and the third is the problem with
the technique we use to generate those
knock out those condition or anything so
there are all the criticism we try to
address those so the first criticism is
a lack of skills how come we can assess
ability to generate these gene editing
mice one is simple is to use ATO
efficiencies of the generation of point
detection are epoxy and what we did is
to collect data on 330 si and in terms
of data that was quite considerable
because it was on over 64,000 zygotes
and out of the CC four thousand cycles
we ten thousand life purpose and with
1369 collect mutation which correspond
to 30% which is within the average of
success for HDR computation and the
number of genes
successful were total fit from Earth and
Mars or successful which means as a
whole we do I will escape to deny those
single point mutation with a design on
soil the two other questions what about
the technique
so the way we address these is as you
can see the original technique is to
generate double-stranded break so to cut
for the exon and to replace with the
true a single trinomial and what we did
we compared with all the techniques that
use these vectors or so transgenic a
speed or not funny to me go that replies
not a chunk of DNA and what we did is to
compare side by side for a genotype so
if I summarize all of these so we are
four techniques they are one with the
original technique the bottom side of
the table
so the trolly go local guide we did the
control insertion so what that means is
we do the to kite or ego approach and
only 1 out of 2 loxp since octave so
what we did is to take those mice
breathe and then later on in sunday
second one and through the techniques on
the top are the long strands Iranian
rial and the DNA plasmid and we what I
would like to grow I draw your attention
to is the last part of the table on the
rectangle in the title screen section
and as you can see was or significant
the efficiency in insulting both rods p
was significantly here for all the
techniques except to compare the two
guys through your technique what that
means it means that if i wreck of a
combination that are required for low
spin intention so explain what that
means is basically when you insert the
true guy truly go so the recipe visitor
guide for ego technique you need to
combination even procure where hard with
the other technique
you only need one which is the insertion
of the large chunk of DNA to be
successful in generating the conditional
it doesn't mean that this truly guide
through legal approach doesn't work it
just means it's less efficient this
technique could be very useful for
example to insert locks beside Atari far
away from one to another so what it
means in terms of outcome for the to
guide to legal technique firstly we see
a lot of one loss pieces in some so that
we can take advantage of this by
generating this human one and we see a
lot of indents the break or the
combination of in decibels P or loxp not
in the right side of the laceration
between those exams oh nothing at all so
that's a large range of outcome and this
is lead to the fact that it's this
technique needs to illumination events
instead of one so what is my take on
this one firstly as you as you've seen
in this presentation replication from
civil laboratory is a waste of time
funds on a fault with default in the
world importantly and you probably of
malaria now first vacation P love you
social media rulers of copán servers
such as by archive is considerably
changing the mutation landscape and to
give you a very telling example oh it
does changing landscape I bless give you
an example so in the 30th of May 2017
the paper
Spanish on stating that Chris burkas
gives a lot of fun tongue or [ __ ] FX
in mouth Sabri
I won't go into the details but it was
an unmarked paper which natural methods
that day and myself and colleague were
very much not impressed with the quality
of the paper there were some flaws we
pointed out pretty much couple of hours
after after was published on Twitter and
this is false upon my Twitter feed and I
decided couple of days after to write a
blog post about this paper and basically
summarizing what are the flaws in this
paper while we why we shouldn't trust
the data on this paper I did it
three to four days after so it was
really quick in couple of hours we find
that the paper was fraud we shared and
ideally to go with the blog post what
happened next is a little bit later my
colleagues published on by ourselves
some concern about the papers it's only
free but there were many demos on de
Vaca it was couple of fixes to way after
this premature year after year published
on collection and follow up on these
studies showing that in fact the study
the original study was fruit which leads
to refraction of the papers of our years
and it is was follow with web perform
studies for support showing from economy
understand here showing that eat this
off target effects house no that was a
ocean of self well not view and we with
my colleague from the Sangha we recently
discussed this in this paper so the last
steak I
like to give a conclusion is read if we
need met recently
comminuted approaches to validate a
technique the problem the ribbon problem
or the crystal field or the field
biology is too many studies of to small
sample size underpowered and what we've
seen in fact rather the general case and
this is really potent to address and we
I believe the use of cleaned social
media recently study we can address this
issue and I have convinced that we can
so to finish I would like to thank all
the people in my laboratory that has
been critical for this work or the
funding agencies that me to perform this
and of course all the collaborators that
are involved in this to go right through
single-stranded read watch and thank you
for your attention